Is it?
It is the case that we live in a field.
It's defined by the extent of our vision.
It is the case that we live in a
hierarchical structure on that plane.
It is the case that there's
a king ship at the top.
It is the case that that's always
threatened by malevolence and sin.
It is the case that that can make you
corrupt and cynical and irresponsible.
It is the case that that's the
inappropriate response and that it's your
responsibility to repair
the damage structure of
tradition despite the fact that
it veers towards corruption.
It is the case that if you take
that responsibility on yourself,
that the rain falls again
and everything flourishes.
It's correct.
It's the right way of
looking at the world,
and if we didn't know that deeply,
everyone in this room wouldn't
have watched that movie.
And you think,
well,
it's so strange that we can watch
that movie without understanding it.
Right?
You can fall into it because you do.
When you go to,
you might wonder,
well,
do people have religious experiences?
Because people wonder about
the truth of religion,
let's say,
and I'm not going to go
very deeply into that issue,
but I can tell you that what you're doing
when you go to a movie like that that
has that mythological
structure and you fall into it,
which is what you do,
that what you're having is absolutely
indistinguishable from a religious
experience.
It's the revelation of
knowledge that you know,
but you don't know.
You know,
and there's something about it that's so
deeply engaging in meaningful that you
will line up and pay for the
privilege of being exposed to it.
And this is not an easy
thing to understand.
Like if you bring,
your child will be very excited about the
possibility of going to the lion king,
right?
And maybe want to watch it 20 times.
My son watched the d,
The whale seen in Pinocchio.
I bet he watched that 115 times
when he was four or five years old.
He just watched it over
and over and over and over.
I thought,
what the hell are you doing kid?
You know?
I mean,
it was so interesting to watch
that he was so obsessed by it.
But there's a tremendous amount
of information in that movie,
like a,
an almost unlimited amount of information.
And he was gripped by it and was trying,
however it is that a child's imagination
tries to come to terms with what the
movie was representing.
And it wasn't like he enjoyed it.
Not at all.
Not In the least.
You know?
And if you,
well,
if you,
if you watch the scene,
how many of you have
seen the Movie Pinocchio?
Okay.
So it's the same thing.
It's one of the 10 most highest
grossing movies of all time,
by the way.
Um,
there's a scene where Pinocchio,
who's turned in,
he's a wooden puppet who's been
turned into a jackass and for some,
which is supposed to make sense
to you and apparently does.
And he goes to the bottom of the ocean
to rescue his father who was somehow
swallowed by a whale.
So think about what you're watching.
You're watching a drawing of a
puppet turned into a jackass.
Go to the bottom of the ocean and rescue
his father from a fire-breathing whale
and you're all perfectly okay with that.
Right?
So it's very peculiar and so,
and it's very frightening.
Like the whale is a while it does breathe
fire because it's actually a dragon,
not a whale.
And,
and the,
the animators used locomotive noises to,
to,
to add the audio background and the whale
is hell bent on destroying the hero of
the story of Pinocchio and also Japan and,
and it's a very tense scene.
And so my son was just like this
like the whole time watching it.
It,
it wasn't,
you wouldn't think that he would,
you know,
he's like these terrified,
like a rabbit who's being watched by a
wolf and then it makes his heartbeat and
he's all exhausted and it goes,
and then the first thing he
wants to do is to do it again.
It's like,
what the hell is going well?
What,
what's going on there?
It's not like it's a cake walk.
It's not that at all.
It's like he could hardly
even stand to watch it.
It's so tense,
especially when you're for,
it's like it's bad enough
when you're an adult,
you know,
and you've seen a
thousand things like that.
And at least in principle,
your little tougher and a little wiser.
But when you're for that
just blows you away.
Like,
like everything in the world does.
And yet all he would do is expose himself
to it over and over and over and over
and over.
And in the lion king,
like if you watch children when they go
see that they're just demolished when
Simba,
his father dies,
right?
Just tears them apart.
They can't believe that,
you know,
the king has disappeared.
And yet they'll watch it over and over
and over and over just like you do.
And it's because,
well,
the whole story we used to tell our son
when we took them to movies because he'd
get all shorted out by what was happening.
And unsurprisingly,
watch the hero.
Keep your eye on the hero because
that's the pathway through.
And that's exactly right because you're
supposed to keep your eye on the hero
because that is the pathway through and
there isn't anything that's more true
than that.
That's a true story.
You think?
Well,
it's fictional.
It's like fiction presents abstractions.
Abstractions aren't false hoods.
They're abstractions.
Think about numbers.
Numbers are abstractions.
They're abstracted away from
individual entities in the real world.
But if you know the numbers,
you know abstractions of tremendous truth.
While the abstraction of the idea of the
individual hero from the collective of
human action is the abstraction
of it's more true than true.
Deep fiction is more true than truth.
That's a way of thinking about it.
It's more real than reality itself.
In the same way that an abstraction can
be more real than the thing that it's
abstracted from all of the,
all of the landscape in a mythological
tale like the lion king is an abstract
landscape.
What's common across all landscapes?
Well,
wherever you go,
there are things that you know and
there are things that you don't know and
that's the human world and it doesn't
matter who the human being is.
You might know more than you do,
but doesn't matter because your knowledge
is still bounded by your limitless
ignorance.
And the possibility that that domain of
limitless ignorance will make mockery of
what you know at any moment.
It's a reality and it's
a universal reality,
and you have to orient
yourself in that landscape.
And and so does everyone else.
You have to deal with what you knew
and what you don't know everywhere.
And the way you do that is by straddling
the divide between what you know and
what you don't know.
You do that by staying firmly grounded
to some degree in what you understand,
but by putting a tentative foot outward
into what you don't understand so that
you can remain stable,
but you can stretch yourself and
challenge yourself simultaneously.
Right?
And that's the proper place to stand.
And that's actually a real place.
That's the line between chaos and order.
And that's the place of meaning.